hmm so the good guy's the bad guy
hey descendants fans we've got a big
plot twist coming your way
what if your favorite vks return to
their rotten to the core roots
in descendants 4 or for an even bigger
twist
what if the aks that are so good turn so
bad
as beast says every time we open the
barrier
we're exposed to danger by the end of
descendants 3 the barrier between
auradon and the isle of the lost has
come right down
we're imagining what the fourth
installment of the franchise would look
like if a familiar face became the
shocking new enemy
wow that is beyond exciting
step aside queen of mean audrey you've
got nothing on the new threat to
auradon this is the land of opportunity
we can be
whatever we want to be here of all the
original vks
evie was the most excited to use the
opportunity at auradon prep for positive
ends
she worked hard to keep mal on track
reminding her of their chance as auradon
girls
look at where we are we're in auradon
and we're origon girls now
so it would be a brilliant plot twist in
descendants 4 if evie returned to her
rotten to the core roots
after all she explained to ben and
chillin like a villain that
everybody's got
but why would that happen we reckon it
would be down to her relationship with
doug
going south he helped her discover the
importance of true love
so if he cheated evie would be
heartbroken and that could bring back
her old interest in looks
money and status she'd steal her magic
mirror from the museum
and use it to answer questions that
would help her overthrow mal and ben
and become the wicked queen of auradon
and the isle
are you stalking me technically yes
if evie were to go back to her villain
roots then she could well take doug down
that bad path with her
dopey's son might be desperate to win
her back and do whatever it takes to get
their relationship
back on track he could lure ben into a
trap and lock him away while evie
tricked mal
just imagine this cute couple becoming
the new wicked queen and king of auradon
if that sounds like too much of a
stretch for doug and evie to unite in
wickedness
then doug could turn to evil ways on his
own because of evie breaking up with him
he could steal mal's spellbook from the
museum and use it to fix his
relationship with evie
who would you be more surprised to see
go bad doug
or evie i've decided that the children
on the isle of the lost be given a
chance
to live here in auradon ben has always
stood up for what's right so it would be
shocking if he turned bad
however there's a clear route for him to
embrace his wicked side
and that's through his beast
transformation we saw how angry he got
over a simple thorn in his paw
and gaston's son gill revealed that ben
would have inherited that trait from the
beast
he's got a boo-boo that's why he's so
cranky
you know my dad said that his dad did
not handle pain well
with the barrier down there could be
lots of villains determined to seek
revenge on ben's dad
for sending them away to the isle in
particular gaston could be out for
justice
so he could find a way to hurt ben and
that would drive ben into a wicked
tailspin of
dastardly deeds hi mom i don't know if
you can hear me
but it's been a really crazy day it
would definitely be a surprise if ben
became rotten to the core
and the same goes for jane we all saw
her reaction when she ripped her skirt
in the first movie
trying to look cool she followed
lonnie's lead in altering her outfit
but immediately regretted it what did i
just do
but jane has also shown a rebellious
side like when she grabbed her mom's
wand at ben's coronation
jane also feels a lot of pressure from
fairy godmother to be good
what if that pressure got too much to
handle it would be shocking if she went
full
on wicked as nobody in auradon would see
it coming she could steal her mom's wand
again and use its power to put
everyone under her spell they could be
her puppets doing whatever she wanted
audrey's queen of mean look was fierce
wouldn't you just
love to see evil jane's makeover do you
enjoy
watching innocent people suffer oh yeah
mal has gone on such a journey that it
would be a shame if she started acting
like her mom
but it wouldn't totally be surprising if
she became rotten to the core again
after all she's flip-flopped between
good and evil throughout the franchise
and she's struggled to deal with
conflict in a positive way
she's always felt the pull of the aisle
you don't ever miss
running wild and just breaking all the
rules at the end of descendants 3 it
seemed like mal got her happy ending
but what if life with king ben turned
out to be too boring
ironically it could be the barrier
coming down that causes mal to return to
her roots while working with the vks to
create a united land that includes the
isle of the lost
mal would spend a lot of time with harry
hook they had chemistry
and that spark could be reignited so it
might be bye bye benny boo
and hello hairy hook dove cameron and
thomas darty are dating in real life
so the actors might be keen for this
plot development too
are you i knew it you can take the girl
out of the aisle but she can't take the
owl out of the girl
evie's honorary little sis dizzy
tremaine was totally stoked when ben
invited her to auradon
we'd love you to join us at auradon prep
will you come
sign king ben so it would be a great
twist if disney shook up the newly
united auradon and isle of the lost
we would never have seen that coming as
one of the lucky vk's included in the
second round of transfers to the isle
it would be a seriously ungrateful move
perhaps dizzy would team up with her
fellow transferred vks
celia and the smee twins to make trouble
after all their introduction to auradon
wasn't exactly plain sailing
and with the barrier down dissie's
grandmother lady tremaine and mom
drizella
could convince her to become rotten to
the core once more
who do you think would bring her back to
the good side it would have to be evie
right my dizzy
you do it your way and i'll do mine at
the end of descendants three jay was
heading off on a gap year with gil
you know what would be fun to go rafting
in a jungle river
find a lot of civilization and spending
so much time with a vk could rub off on
jay
in the wrong way gill's villain ways
would remind jay of his roots
jay could start to miss his old life on
the isle and the thrill of stealing
although jay had departed from his dad
jafar's thieving ways
he didn't go on such an emotional
journey as his fellow vks
mal evie and carlos all found romance
with aks and that helped keep them on
the right path
jay got close with lonnie mulan's
daughter but she wasn't in the third
movie
so that leaves a big gap in jay's life
for a bad influence like gil
to creep in it would be an interesting
twist for jay to join the pirate crew
and battle against his former bffs if
lonnie returned for d4
do you think she could convince jay to
come to his senses
that is if lonnie doesn't turn rotten to
the core herself
she was notable by her absence in the
third movie where was she
let's not forget that audrey didn't
appear in descendants 2 and then she
came back with a bang
as the queen of mean and d3 so it would
make sense if lonnie followed that
formula
and reappeared in d4 with a bad attitude
but what could turn her wicked
there are a few possibilities we saw in
the first movie how lonnie was desperate
to be cool
getting mal to change her hair and
ripping her skirt
now i'm cool and then when she was on
her way back from the isle of the lost
in the second movie
she asked jade went in the mood to break
some rules so she's clearly intrigued by
villainous ways
she's also keen to impress her mother
mulan like when jay makes her the swords
and shields
team captain wait until i tell my mom
what better way to make a splash than by
taking over
auradon here take mine if you could
knock all my homework out along with
yours
maybe we could get together sometime
chad charming might be an ak but the son
of cinderella isn't quite so noble as
his fellow ak ben
chad showed just how easily he's led
when he instantly offered up his
services to become
queen of mean audrey's henchman in
descendants 3.
or maybe just a lackey to do your
bidding um
change tires or smoothie runs huh audrey
dropped him as soon as he'd served his
purpose so we'd hope that chad would
have learned from his mistakes
he didn't seem cut out for the wicked
life but he also isn't the sharpest
pencil in the box
so if another character decided to be
the new queen or king
of mean we wouldn't be surprised if chad
volunteered again to be their lackey
you never know make me your queen and
we'll rule side by side
after all of the problems audrey caused
when she became queen of mean
you'd think she would have learned her
lesson and stay on the good side
after hades revived her with his ember
she was certainly apologetic for wanting
to hurt everyone
i'm sorry but this ak isn't necessarily
going to leave her mean side alone
forever
she's proven she's got the smarts and
the guts to steal powerful magical
objects
and once you've had a taste of power
it's that much harder to resist
especially if you're mad because mal has
stolen your bae again
at the end of d3 we see audrey and harry
hook flirting
so if mal wants to get together with
harry it would be like history repeating
itself for audrey with mal taking her
man again
this time around audrey could be smarter
and get a more powerful ally than chad
just imagine if she teamed up with uma
now that would make for a fascinating
descendants for rotten
to the core which character would you
like to see turn bad in d4
let us know in the comments and hit that
subscribe button to be the first to know
when we release more new videos
thanks for watching